my name is marcus one second
last look
um sorry about that my name is marcus
friend
and i am a second second on bethany all
right guys wardrobe is clear
makeup is clear for a second quiet
freeze
lock it up we started i don't know it
was fairly reasonable i think i was up
at six
and i was here by 7 30 so not too bad by
any respect
and what's your day like what do you do
um walk with me uh second second is
basically a caretaker
for the whole crew uh first aid keeps
everything on schedule second ad keeps
everything moving and i keep everyone
awake
so i'll be two seconds
i don't want to sleep yeah
all right cam is moving into position
lastly
and take care of everyone the best you
can i have a great group of pas they
caught on like really fast
but now they're all gone so it's back to
me hi um
essentially you just learn everyone's
chords uh
defazio has a certain way of speaking
when he sets up camera whenever you're
running set and then
i want to say hooker is a sweetheart
and a couple of vegans on set so
all right
james it's fine as long as we flip it
we're just going tight on a door so copy
um and we're
going tight on a door if you guys want
to see what's going on
well aside from that it's just taking
care of actors getting them through the
works
um doing production reports and
seconds one of those awesome jobs that
you have to know a little bit about
everything
so like in a lot of ways you're still a
pa
the difference is you
you know what you're doing so um
but yeah i mean that's that's basically
all i do is just you keep people running
um i make sure that everyone is ready so
the first id calls
rolling um cameras in place the actors
are in place
everyone's been through makeup everyone
knows their lines um i'm that person
that gets here
an hour before call i prep everyone's
trailers i cut everyone's sides
how do you stay organized and calm
because you seem like you're just doing
everything
how do you do that well thank you stay
focused
i don't know it's easy film sets are a
living breathing thing
so as long as you know the pulse then
you can keep pace with it there's
nothing worse than if like if i come to
set and i haven't read the sides or if i
haven't looked at the call sheet then
i'm disorganized but your whole
the whole plan for the day is right here
right to jt because
uh you have every single prop every
single wardrobe change every single
day so read the call sheet and then
write stuff down if you have more than
eight things going but i can usually
juggle about six without thinking about
it
so hold on cool um
they haven't called rolling yet which
makes me worried
do you need to check on them no no no
i'm all good
they got it at this point i think
they're just waiting on tap that's it
and some days it's like this and some
days i'm
some days i'm just working on the
computer and i have time
it all depends camera rolling
tails hey i'm telling you buzz
i think the irony of the situation here
is that i forgot to mention
the major part of my job is keeping the
lines of communication open
hang on
copy you we're walking down and now do
you have eyes on key
you need only the tail end of it right
i'm just going to do it from the top see
what i get just in case i have cut away
it's not like a huge rush just gotta get
married to the first tv um
as soon as it comes out the elevator
whenever there's a change
whenever there's an adjustment um
i have to make sure every department
knows because the first idea is busy
solving the problem on set so i collect
as much information as possible
trying to ask as many questions and then
give it to the first id so that he can
problem solve on the spot
which is why you always see me running
around because i have to know
what's going on everywhere and that's
the major part of my job take care of
the actors get them through the works
and make sure the rest of the crew knows
what's going on
are you doing all this individually
mixture mixture walkies are good but
like
they also there's certain words that are
tricky like names times
um that's why you have terminology like
86 rolling cut let's see
oh uh flipping around dress last looks
it's all stuff that you just kind of
rank so you don't have to totally
understand it
okay cool now we sit quietly so i'm
gonna go back to writing production
reports
we are rolling
you